Продавці розпочинають готуватися до торгівлі заздалегідь.
Займати місця і розкладати товар доводиться за день до події.
Блошиний ринок у Бонні - це до двох тисяч продавців
і кілька сотень тисяч відвідувачів щоразу.
Класно прийти сюди, зустріти веселих людей, .
і до того ж, тут відмінні ціни
Я купила сьогодні намисто ручної роботи.
А моя подруга придбала книги німецькою.
Вона приїхала до Німеччини на семестр
і збирається вчити німецьку мову.
Я купила цікаву річ для будинку.
А також дві хокейні ключки для моїх синів.
Будуть грати вдома, у дворі.
Навіщо цим речам припадати пилом на полицях,
каже Моніка, продавець зі стажем,
адже комусь це таки може знадобитись.
Для неї блошиний ринок - це місце, де можна не тільки
продати товар, а й поспілкуватися з людьми.
Відвідувачі блошиного ринку шукають щось особливе.
Вони шукають те, чого точно не знайти в супермаркеті.
На цьому ринку можна знайти все, що завгодно:
взуття, антикваріат, різноманітні речі...
Такого в магазинах немає.
Блошиний ринок чимось нагадує азартну гру:
це і популярна розвага, і захоплююча прогулянка одночасно.
На дні коробки з якимось мотлохом може виявитися справжній скарб.
А от чого не варто купувати на блошиному ринку, так це
електротехніку, якою вже користувалися, впевнений Маркус.
Продавець з тридцятирічним стажем вважає,
що краще дивитися у напрямку прикрас.
Він колекціонує мінерали й корали.
Мені здається, німці дуже люблять старі речі.
Одна людина каже: я це викину, а інша: ой, яка прекрасна річ.
Вона точно стане в нагоді.
На думку торговців, блошиний ринок забезпечує
кругообіг старих речей у природі.
Вони впевнені, що завдяки цьому німці змогли зберегти
величезну кількість унікальних старих речей у гарному стані.
Деякі відвідувачі полюють на справжній скарб.
Наприклад, на одному з блошиних ринків кілька років тому
за 5 євро придбали картину французького
імпресіоніста П'єра-Огюста Ренуара.
А згодом з'ясувалося, що реальна вартість полотна -
понад сто тисяч євро.